it's not easy to see what these sheets
will become they're a mixture of paper
and the stems of papyrus reeds they're
spread out on large surfaces these women
are using the sheets to make sanitary
pads the need for sanitary protection is
huge especially in schools where
hygienic conditions are bad many girls
can't afford imported sanitary pads
Moses masazi an engineering professor at
makarora University in Kampala has
developed a safe and cheap locally made
alternative maka pants they told me
something I didn't know that some girls
who are too poor to afford sanitary pads
missed going to school all the days they
are menstruating that means three to
five days in a month they wouldn't go to
school progressively they would perform
badly and then drop out of school
without cooperating education Moses
masazi and his colleagues experimented
for three years to develop a model that
worked the papyrus reeds grow on the
outskirts of Kampala they're abundant
and are easily processed to make the
maca pads workers cut the papyrus peel
off the green cover and then take the
white stems to the factory
the work is done by people who live next
to the fields the maca pods project is
aimed at creating jobs for the needy
unemployed women and refugees from the
Democratic Republic of the Congo and
Central Africa are given preference just
under two hundred people now work in the
factory production takes 40 steps and
almost everything is done by hand the
idea was to employ as many people as
possible
and using as little energy as possible
therefore use the Sun or solar in the
production but to employ many many
people out of it they've been making the
maca pads in Kampala for ten years this
is already the third production site
Julie naka bula has been there since the
beginning she's now that general manager
yeah it's really funny being a man he
has been able to invent a sanitary pad
which he does not obviously used for
biological reasons but then because he's
a genius in innovations Moses masazi
derives inspiration from his immediate
surroundings my side as a father maca
Potts has made a huge impact first of
all my daughter and wife use maca pods
but most importantly that they are very
proud of me for having been able to
innovate something out of what it would
call grass that is pakoras into a
product they're so cheap that not only
Uganda schools but also the UNHCR
refugee organization wants them my
future plans from the maca paths are
twofold the first one I want similar
paths marketed outside the the Ugandan
borders I know are born to Surrey on and
little bit beyond once America parts as
a home product in
moisés masazi is expanding the business
and he can hardly keep up with
production his simple idea has improved
the lives of many women in Africa